hello everyone and welcome to another
super exciting game from round six of
this year's super bit chess classic the
game just finished it's already versus
linear dominguez perez uh and the both
of them uh are are not having a
brilliant tournament but uh
linear had uh at least one victory in
the previous round he defeated um
daniel dak and uh he well he he got his
one win that's more than alireza got uh
so far he only has draws and that one
laws that um
that we've checked out uh but this game
alireza has the white pieces and he
decided to give it everything he's got
and well i'm not gonna spoil what
happens but it does look like uh like
something you guys will enjoy so let's
dive straight into it alert has the
white pieces and he opens with d4 and
yes we will have another nimzo indian
knight to f6 we have c for e6 knight the
c3 and the bishop the b4 the name so
indian defense is on the board
we have e3 going for the traditional or
rather the normal line we have castles
and now bishop to d3 going for the
bishop attack uh d5 striking in the
center c captures with e captures and e5
and now a3 challenging the bishop here
uh this is a very rare uh usually just
knight to the e2 is played but alireza
wants to mix it up he plays a3
bishop back to d6 and now queen to c2
putting pressure on that h7 pawn we have
c6 strengthening the center and knight g
to e2 so nothing new here uh rook the e8
and now bishop to d2 we have b6 now
preparing to develop the light square
bishop maybe to b7 maybe to e6 uh and
here the game like i said or rather the
position is a known one for example
levon arunian had it against david in
this year's video grand prix two months
ago where just castles was played uh but
here alireza plays f3 and it is now as
of movie 11 that we have a completely
new game so what is this f3 move all
about well you control g4 and d4 so
obviously you are controlling the knight
very nicely also you have very nice
support for executing e for all of your
pieces and pawns are
going after that e4 square but for the
moment your king is still in the center
of the board so probably you're going to
castle before before doing something
like this but after dominguez plays this
c5 idea which is a very nice contrary to
the f3 idea you're threatening c4 and
that will trap the bishop on d3
alireza plays g4 and here you already
know that it's going to be a wild game
now what is alireza saying here he's
saying that if uh
linear plays c4
the only square for the bishop available
is bishop to f5 and then well that's
basically the challenge all it is it
says this is what i've prepared are you
interested in playing this and c4 is in
fact the strongest move recommended by
the engine uh so it is no wonder that
linear playset because it it is a good
move i mean what is white to do so
bishop to f5 and here black says all
right i'm gonna trade my undeveloped
bishop that wasn't really doing all that
much for your monster bishop that was
controlling this diagonal so what do you
have in mind here the ship captures and
now queen captures an f5 g captures
looks very aggressively you do get the
semi-open g file for your rook
but
it's not it's not all that impressive a
black can go king h8 rook rook to g8 and
you're not going to be able to put all
that much pressure on that um
g7 pawn so instead we have queen
captures on f5 and now g6 attacking the
queen here queen g5 and now just knight
to c6 continuing development uh here
alireza finally castles and now bishop
to f8 so now the dark squares around the
black king have been weakened and the
dark square bishop will
be a very nice defender of those dark
squares so here we have queen to h4
already wants to bring the queen back
all the way to f2 he doesn't want to
allow linear to trade queens and he
wants to start advancing his uh h pawn
trade here open up the h file uh and
then who knows what might happen so here
h6 we have rook eight to d1 and b5 now
preparing a5 and b4 queen back to f2 as
planned and now queen to d sub that's
not a d7 queen to d7 uh we have queen
the g2
now gaining more control over the over
the e4 square uh and now the ship to g7
so and nicely uh uh finishing up the
defensive setup and alireza starts
pushing we have h4
knights the e7 and now knight to f4 so
slowly building up the pressure on the
king side but uh doesn't seem like
there's uh all that much to do yeah it's
not like the a breakthrough will happen
so here linear says all right i'm just
going to continue playing on the queen
side as you really have nothing on the
kings side knight c to e2 and now queen
to b7 gaining more control over d4
square but also adding pressure to the
b4 uh square you want to push that b for
pawn at some point uh g5 uh attacking
the knight and the pawn h captures h
captures and now knight to d7 so alireza
uh got what he wanted but what is his
actual plan now this is a a very nice
position to just you know soak in and
figure out you're playing white here how
would you continue uh feel free to pause
the video and you know try to find the
the well the best way for whites to
continue playing this uh while i give
you a couple of seconds
so for those of you who were able to do
it congratulations on finding the move
alireza played and for those of you who
just want to enjoy the show it is king
to f2 that's the point that we wanted to
exchange our h1 open up the h file and
now we're going to double up on the h
file or maybe even triple up our best uh
best case scenario is for example
something like rook to h4 queen to h2
and the other rook on h1 and then we can
play rook to h8 check the bishop
captures and queen delivers checkmate on
h8 so that's the dream scenario uh if uh
well white can just have his way but of
course black will also have a few moves
but black says this is nothing to worry
about linear just place b4 continues
playing on the queen side rook to h1 by
alireza we have knight to f5 and now
queen to h3 uh so this this is the setup
that alireza chooses we have knight back
to e7 and now knight the g3 bringing the
other knight into the attack as well we
have rook to a6 uh and now comes a
captures on b4 uh we have eight captures
on b4 and now the tricky bishop captures
on b4 and this is um
well this is a very very uh
double-edged okay uh elereza grabs the
pawn he gives up the bishop here to grab
the knight on d7 but then the black
queen will pick up the b coupon
delivered check then he gives linear the
past c pawn so this is uh completely
crazy linear goes for this as so far
everything alireza plays is just good
for linear uh and uh he he just accepts
every challenge along the way queen
captures on d7 now comes uh rook88 uh
getting the rook back to help out with
the defense and now knight f to e2 uh so
now queen captures here will not come
with check so
linear doesn't bother capturing the pawn
right away first rook eight to d8 uh
kicking away the queen from such an
active square queen to g4 and now queen
captures on b2 and now he just wants to
push his pass pawn to victory uh so what
did alersa have in mind here oh it is a
place queen to f4 and this is a such a
beautiful beautiful tricky move that if
you're not careful yeah it will just
cost you the game and the linear was not
careful here uh he has to play something
like rook to a8 or just continue pushing
with with something like c3
but uh he played knight to c6 and this
simply will not do so okay there are
some tactics in the air you can see that
the rook is x-raying the knight here the
queen also uh so maybe if the knight
captures here and the bishop then maybe
the position opens up and you can
capture on e2 so there are a lot of
things possible uh but there were just
um uh much much better moves for a
linear here and this allows all it is to
play a spectacular
winning move uh so once again feel free
to pause the video and try to find this
idea while i give you a couple of
seconds
so uh for those of you who are able to
do it congratulations on realizing the
true meaning of queen to f4 and for
those of you who just want to enjoy the
show the move of course is rook to h7
this is what alireza played and now
there is not all that much linear can do
so congratulations to everyone who
spotted this uh it's not an easy move to
find but if you know about this tactic
that of course if the king captures the
h file is open and you can gobble up the
f7 pawn then of course the queen from f7
guards g8 and g6 and rook to h1 will be
checkmate so of course you cannot
capture this if you capture queen
captures and there's no stopping rook to
h1 uh this is game over so now linear
plays rook to e6 it is the only story
rook to e6 uh it is the only move that
keeps the game going uh unfortunately uh
for him uh not for very long here queen
to h4 and now we get the setup that
we've uh discussed earlier i mentioned
okay rook and h for queen and hd and the
other rook on h1 but this also works
rook h7 queen and h4 the other rook on
h1 rook h8 check will pretty much end
the game uh so here the only good move
for linear is knight captures on d4 this
is what he plays and it's uh it's a very
slim uh there's a very slim chance that
all it is he captures on d4 and then he
will survive the attack for example he
goes to rook d to e8 puts pressure on
the knight here and now you really don't
have anything better other than to
capture here play rook h1 and now after
king to f8 which is the only move that
saves the game queen h6 check king to e7
and now queen to g7 uh looks very scary
but okay at least now you're not going
to be able to capture the king is in
between the rooks so the game goes on a
little bit but it's kind of black who's
maybe better and you you you have
escaped certain doom so this would be
great however alireza doesn't fall for
this he just plays rook captures on g7
with check and now there is not all that
much for linear to do king captures on
g7 this is the only move queen captures
on d4 alireza trades down into a winning
end game queen captures rook captures
and this is the position that we have uh
okay now of course uh this is uh
this will be uh played so if of course
spawn captures then the rook and d8
falls so rook to d6 and now just knight
to c3 and it's a terrible terrible
position for black two knights against
the rook uh like i said it's a
completely winning end game and it is
only a matter of time before alireza
wins but he has already been in such a
situation this tournament and he was
unable to take the full point so let's
see how the game continued we have f6 uh
g captures king captures black activates
the king knight g to e2 now we have to
get that knight into the game king the
e5 and now rook the g4 going um
for f4 and rook to g5 setup we have rook
to g8 adding a defender to the pawn here
knight the d4 now we have rook to d7 now
comes rook g5 to king f6 and f4 so
alareza wins more space for his king
rook g back to d8 and then now rook back
to e5 we have king f7 now comes rook g5
and now rook to h8 so there's nothing
for el nino to do here but to wait and
see what alireza does knight to f3
guards h2 but also just prepares to win
the game on the spot so king g7
rook to g1
uh preparing to shift the rook uh
the other way around we have rook to b7
and rook to a1 now rook to d8
again defending the pawn here uh knight
to d4 now again knight's the e6 check
wins the game so rook d to d7 uh getting
the rook away from that d8 square rook
to a5 now increasing the pressure here
so now the d5 pawn can no longer be
defended and here linear tries one last
idea g5 with f5 rook to b2 with check
and king to f3 we have rook to d2 now
putting some pressure on white's
position but just knight captures on d5
there's really nothing to hope for here
c3 he starts advancing the pawn
but not just knight to e6 check and he
was in this position on move 58 that a
linear dominguez pair has resigned the
game as there is nothing more to be done
here the king is in check and it doesn't
matter what you play if you bring the
king closer to the knight we can just
capture here and after the knight moves
again we can capture here there is no
counter play for black here whatsoever
you have zero pawns white has two pawns
and two knights against the rook so of
course completely winning and if you go
up uh with the king then you are even
getting checkmated rook to a8 checking
f7 rook to f8 is checkmate and also if
you go to h7 then we just bring the
other knight knight to f6 with king h6
rook to h8 to check king rook h7 only
move and of course rook captures on h7
will be checkmate so after this knight
to e6 move uh dominguez uh perez resigns
and alireza gets his first win in the
tournament which brings him back all the
way to 50 percent uh and we'll see will
he be able to
get a few more points for from the last
two games but
it's it's a very tough he is the only
2800 player in the tournament so every
draw means a rating loss for him and a
loss is is just losing too much rating
so he really needs those wins uh in
order to remain a member of the 2800
club alongside magnus and the ding uh so
that's the first game we're showing from
round seven hope you guys enjoyed it so
really
really brought out the the big guns for
this one he really prepared extremely
well for this with f3 and uh
well after g4 uh dominguez accepted the
challenge with c4 i mean look at this
such a such a funny line
uh well basically he prepared well uh
dominguez played really well but it all
came down to that one move where he
allowed this spectacular rook to h7 idea
and after that there just wasn't
anything else the knight on c6 it just
does not help out with the position
whatsoever and rook h7 is just a
brilliant brilliant move to uh to
win the game for alireza uh so yeah once
again hope you guys uh enjoyed it uh i
would like to thank claudio bravely and
alessandro bossie yogeshpatki donating
because it is the strongest move person
tarek aldalal and rip market for your
contribution to my channel thank you a
lot i really appreciate it as usual you
can check two of my previous videos here
thank you for watching and i will see
you soon continuing to check up on your
wonderful suggestions
and whatever else happens in the chess
world so thank you all i will see you
soon and have an excellent rest of your
day